so what happened last night we had an
annual general meeting and there was a
motion of confidence in me tabled by my
officers and they did that because they
had received representations from people
who wanted to table a motion of
no-confidence but that was out of order
because it had been doubt because of the
way it was tabled and the person who
tabled it was in fact not a member of
the Association at the time they had
done so at the meeting there were a very
large number of people turned up about I
don't know probably around a hundred of
whom I had certainly never had seen or
met before in my years as a member of
parliament and there is clear evidence
that there was an orchestrated campaign
by my UK
opponent in 2017 who since joined the
association with the express intention
of trying to come along and defeating
the motion and they were successful in
doing that it was slightly rowdy meeting
although the chair was able to keep it
under reasonable control but certainly
it wasn't the sort of Conservative Party
meeting as I'm used to attending yes so
tell us a little bit more about who you
believe is behind this you're referring
to John Conway
yes mr. Conway stood against me in 2017
I understand he subsequently informed
the Association that he had left yook it
was no longer interested in it and that
he wanted to join the Association and he
actually said I don't wish to cause any
trouble I'm just wished to join as a
northern remember those were a broad
church he was admitted but the evidence
I think is pretty plain that he
organized both bringing members into the
Association and also organised
preliminary meetings prior to this AGM
taking place for the express single
purpose of coming to defeat the motion
of confidence in me 350 people attended
the local Conservative Association
chairman said that it was a broad Church
a wide variety of views a wide variety
of opinions robust discussion ultimately
it went against you because of your
views about brexit it isn't the local
party in title
to do that I should emphasize that the
local Association is fully entitled to
express its views that I've always known
that Breck's it's very divisive and I'm
totally respectful of the views of those
who disagree with me as to the way I've
approached this particular crisis
historically though the Conservative
Party being a broad church doesn't seek
to expel members of parliament for
variations of you otherwise many of my
colleagues who currently have good
careers in Parliament would never have
been able to remain there so this is
rather unusual and it has to be seen
also against two backgrounds one 1,100
members of the Association in total so
many of course weren't there and
secondly there are about thirty six
thousand people in Bekins field who vote
conservative and one of the anxieties I
have is I get streams and emails
including this morning from people who
vote conservative in my constituency who
are appalled at the way brexit is
unfolding and very troubled about what
they're hearing and I fear very much
that if the party isn't able to get to
grips with this problem and simply
becomes a single issue group of school
then our ability to win elections in
future is going to be very limited but
there was seventeen point four million
people who voted to leave the EU that
was supposed to happen at 11 o'clock
last night it hasn't happened and the
feeling is that you are behind moves to
frustrated brexit is frustrating itself
by this idea this conspiracy theory that
people are conspiring to prevent it
simply flies in the face of reality the
reason why the Prime Minister has not
been able to get her deal through
Parliament is not through bad faith it's
because of the fact that the deal when
it's examined whether by levers or
remainders looks and points to an
utterly second-rate relationship for our
future with Europe and our future as a
country compared to remaining in indeed
some of my ERG colleagues have even
admitted themselves they prefer to
remained and have such a deal now the
Prime Minister has been doing her best
course she has
Specter for it but the truth is there
isn't a deal which is going to deliver a
form of brexit which is going to be
better than what we have at the moment
and it's the growing realization of this
which is making those who are fixated on
achieving brexit more and more vocal and
at the same time is the reason why we
can't get a consensus in Parliament
because MPs doing their best and trying
to act on their constituents behalf can
see so plainly but what be likely
outcomes are not very good ones for our
country so what are we to do about it I
accept the 2016 referendum is really
important and the result that we have to
keep in mind but my solution is to go
back and ask people what they want
because I I'm simply not prepared to
drag people out of the EU into a future
which they don't want 14% support the
Prime Minister's deal at the moment can
we find another deal that people would
be more comfortable with I'm prepared to
do that but what I'm not prepared to do
is to sign off the country's future and
drag it to the destination that on the
face of it people don't want in terms of
what's next for you personally at
Dominic grieve George Osborne the former
Chancellor has tweeted that the
Conservative Party head office could
intervene and suspend the local party
have you had any conversations with CC
HQ I would be very concerned if the
local party was suspended my officers
are right thinking and extremely good
people and the Association is run by
very good people so I've always had it's
a functioning Association I'm sure that
we need to pay some attention to the
extent to which infiltration has taken
place and the extent to which there may
be members of the Association who in
fact are not there for legitimate
reasons that having been said my
intention is to carry on as before of
course as I said last night at the
meeting I note what people have said who
criticized me and some people came and
criticized me while still supporting me
and I'm very grateful for their
criticisms and I will continue to keep
that in mind as we try to find a way out
of this current crisis